and I feel a bit of a fraud actually
because let's face it the reason why I
won this was not because of the hours I
put in all the carefully crafted speech
it's because I referred to male
genitalia during the course of it and
that was not the first time I have done
that on the floor of the house when I
was at Dartmouth doing my reservist
training some of my Marine training
officers thought it would be a good idea
to try and break the ladylike persona
that I maintained throughout the whole
of my course by getting me to as a sort
of mercy word yell particular rude words
during the most grueling part of our
training and I'm having to say that they
failed in that but during our missed
dinner at the end of the course I was
fined for I think a misdemeanor of not
eating my salad or something like that
and they fine was to say a particular
word the abbreviation of cockerel
several times during a speech on the
floor of the House of Commons and
mention all of the officers names
present so I would direct you to Hansard
where you can scroll down the usual list
of topics that I talk about the UK's
place in the world why we need carry a
strike force the deterrent renewal and
you will find unusually for someone
representing an urban seat the Easter
adjournment debate on poultry welfare so
for that and my the speech thank you
very much